guys really quick I just want to remind
you that I did have the opportunity to
interview the entire cast of TNT's
legends Sean Bean Ali Larter and Morris
Chestnut those videos are all on my
channel TNT was super nice to me and
they wanted me to remind you guys to go
check out their YouTube channel you can
do that in the link in my description
below if you like what you see subscribe
because they treat their fans nicely
thanks very much guys
Dracula untold is the rights retaining
film by Universal starring Luke Evans as
Dracula Luke Evans visits a vampire who
turns him into a vampire so that he can
have supernatural forces so that he can
save his family from these oncoming
forces who are threatening to eliminate
everyone that he cares about Dracula
untold to me is the type of movie that
needs more bees and what I mean by that
is we need some Nicolas Cage up in this
thing we need some nickel as cage
Dracula that swamp that's what this
movie needed the thing about this movie
is that it is kind of an interesting
idea we haven't seen a big-budget
Dracula movie since what Dracula mm Wow
poor Dracula he's had a bad run the
problem with this movie in my opinion is
that it takes itself way too seriously
this is an absurd movie this is a really
dumb movie at its core this movie needs
to be dumb and absurd and fun and
hilarious and awesome but it takes
itself so darkly grimly serious that you
can't sit and have any real enjoyment
with this movie it's missing out on the
awesome pleasures that a movie about a
guy who turns himself into Dracula so
that he can fight armies should have see
in the wake of Christopher Nolan's
excellent Batman trilogy every single
movie now that normally would be viewed
as kind of silly or more fun is trying
to be incredibly serious and yet not
every one of those movies needs to be
that way we don't always need a serious
adaptation of everything in a movie
about a guy who climbs a mountain to
find a vampire in a cave to turn him
into Dracula so that he can then turn
into an army of bats and punch people
with a bat hand that forms with those
bats that movie needs to be awesome but
this movie is trying so hard to make you
cry and care about Drac
and his wife and his son you don't need
that in a movie called Dracula untold
where all the things I just said happen
what you need is a really good time and
since this movie is so intent on doing
the opposite of that you can't really
have fun with it that being said it's
not an awful looking movie there are
times where the cinematography is really
gorgeous
I do like Luke Evans I think he's pretty
great in the Hobbit movies and I thought
he was really fun in this movie called
no-one lives which no one really saw and
that films tone is the type of vibe I
feel that this movie was lacking I know
the movie at Luke Evans has been in his
fast in the Furious 6 a movie that
totally knew what it was it was a stupid
cheesy dumb action movie and it had all
those elements to it and it understood
that but this movie is so serious and it
just doesn't work another thing about
this movie is it becomes very apparent
that they're just trying to get that
pg-13 rating this movie should not have
a movie with Dracula in the title should
be rated R okay because a lot of the
movie is filmed beautifully the
cinematography is very nice some of the
sets in the production design are very
good and then as soon as a battle
sequence starts it turns into the first
Hunger Games movie it's shaking all over
the place you can't tell what's going on
because they have limits they can't show
certain things because if they do
they'll get a rated R so in all honesty
I'm just tired of these attempts at
rebooting classic monster movies like
earlier this year's I Frankenstein which
was even worse than this movie so can we
just avoid these classic monster reboots
what's next The Mummy again actually
they're already planning one for 2016 if
it doesn't star Brendan Fraser I don't
care I'm gonna give Dracula untold a
c-minus it's a movie that looks really
good Luke Evans is fun as the title role
and Sarah Gadon as his wife is great but
the movie is just so darkly grim that
you can't have any fun with the movie
where you should be having a lot of fun
with it and it's just really
uninteresting as a story in all honesty
it doesn't really work so guys if you
did see Dracula untold what are your
thoughts on it let me know below and as
always thank you so much for watching
and if you like this you can click right
here and get stuck my nice